so what is the origin of the law well we
don't know for certain but we think it
comes out of mesopotamia no not
hammurabi's code that dates from the
18th century bce specifically the city
state of ur and then ruler ur namu
around the year 2100 bce now there are
some earlier references to a set of laws
from urukagina in the 24th century bce
but the ernamu code is the oldest extant
set of laws that we still have it's
written in a set of if-then statements
if someone does this then this happens
so not surprisingly if a man commits
murder he shall be killed if a man
commits robbery he shall be killed but
what's particularly interesting about
this code is that unlike the later
babylonian codes like hammurabi which
purely focus on retribution an eye for
an eye this creates a set of monetary
compensation for certain acts so for
example if you cut off a man's foot you
owe that person 10 shekels of silver if
you knock out someone's tooth you owe
them two shekels of silver so this is
fairly advanced stuff in part of the
sumerian renaissance of the time and
that is as far as we can tell the origin
of the law